[Music]
give me a relationship update what's
going on where's joy in life and joined
the kids and have a good time we love
each other we're having a blast just
gotten stronger since the show and in
the past couple months right
I feel like we've been through a lot in
the past couple of months I mean it's
kind of emerging our families together
he brought his dog with him he's leading
my kids so a lot but I feel like we
definitely gotten stronger out of it
we're really happy so how hard is that
transition from island life to real life
we were away from work we didn't have
her cell phones I was away from my kids
just like everything so it's like then
we got back to real life and he moved
across the country to live with us and
it's been different but it's been good
we like it good to sit good decision
like it's been a great decision yeah I
love her little ones more than anything
so we're having a lot of fun out here
and we're excited are you guys what do
you play anything like what is the
status of that we've been talking about
a little bit but I mean we've been so
busy and hectic in our own lives
hopefully planning a date that weird at
all to see Nick tonight no not at all we
wish them nothing but the best
I mean we've moved on from everything
we're very happy in our lives and we
wish them nothing but success in his
what are you guys doing for the holidays
his family and my family are all flying
out to Orange County so we're gonna have
like a big family get-together just
gonna be a lot of fun they love a man in
the kids we did get the Elf on the Shelf
the other day we just started it like
two days ago and it's our first time
doing it and also I've never had a real
Christmas tree and we don't have one yet
but I think this week
[Music]